seit mittwoch werden in ganz deutschland
die korona maßnahmen gelockert weil die
infektionszahlen für politik und
experten bundesweit tief genug gesunken
sind und es gibt richtig positive
nachrichten aus einem dorf in sachsen
denn dieses dorf ist corona frei das
kroner virus hat die ganze welt
angegriffene die wirtschaft fast völlig
lahmgelegt wie durch ein wunder wurde
das sächsische dorf rowrah dauer von den
gefährlichen virus verschont jurist
nicht was corona ist 4500 bürger und der
verwaltungsgemeinschaft weiter alle sind
wo wir schieben es eben auf den
ländlichen haben weil im ländlichen raum
sind wir sowieso nicht so in ein
ballungsgebiet sondern wir bewegen uns
mit den geforderten abständen
diese form stehen auch schon als
lakonischer basis und obwohl von corona
in dem dorf keine gefahr auszugehen
scheint nehmen die bürger die
verordneten kroner maßnahmen sehr ernst
die sind richtig diszipliniert die
halten sogar beim spazierengehen den
abstand ein die masken auf und halten
sich natürlich daran dass wir nur durch
die fensterscheibe sprechen wir wollen
ja auch denn in den sommer frisch
fröhlich gehen dass das alles wieder zum
normalzustand kommt und die älteren
bürger sind schon noch so ddr geprägt so
die können was aushalten und sind
wirklich diszipliniert disziplin und
viel freiraum für kontaktlose bewegung
könnten der grund dafür sein dass das
dorf röderer in sachsen corona frei ist
genau in diesem dorf steht jetzt mein
bild kollege carsten k carsten wie genau
kann es sein dass genau ein ein dorf in
der statistik in sachen corona nicht
irgendwo erscheint ja also auch die
brüder aua selbst können darüber nur
spekulieren und das haben sie heute auch
getan wir haben uns mit vielen runden
hier unterhalten können
und die sagten eben ja wir sind von
grunde auf optimistische menschen bei
uns ist dieses berühmte glas immer halb
voll und nicht halb leer
wir leben hier sehr naturverbunden wir
haben eigenheime wir gehen oft an die
frische luft und das natürlich so der
klassische grund ist um corona zu
vermeiden kann ich jetzt auch nicht
sagen
auf jeden fall eine sehr gute
einstellung aber kassen wie kann es denn
sein
wie geht man damit um wenn man gesund
ist und trotzdem sich an die korona
maßnahmen halten muss ja na ja das ist
dass das ist so die geschichte also die
leute sehen ist aber ein das wurde ja
auch schon in der maz am anfang gesagt
sie sind alle hier sehr diszipliniert
und der bürgermeister lothar herklotz
der unterstrich auch noch mal also hier
hält sich jeder an die abstandsregelung
hier werden bei den 130 geschäften
ließen der verwaltungsgemeinschaft wie
immer diszipliniert masken getragen und
vielleicht war das natürlich auch er der
pragmatische grund dass hier überhaupt
nichts passiert ist
vielen herzlichen dank carsten k